so thank you for your for coming to this
presentation uh my name's Mike K Smith I
lead up the our center of excellence and
the swap team and on the 3D of October
this year 2023 I'll be celebrating 30
years employed at
fiser and in the talk today what I want
to to try and um talk to you about is
the fact that right now in Industry
things are changing and things are
changing fast uh because the industry is
looking at our and other open source
tools more and more for clinical trial
reporting and for regulatory
submissions so I want to look at that in
the context of what was it like 30 years
ago where how far have we come and also
a little bit of crystal ball gazing
about what the future might be
like so hope this will works is it maybe
not let's try that so let's jump in the
DeLorean set the destination for 1993
October and go back and see what things
are like I will be your doc EMT Brown
guide to this but when we get back there
we might meet this young lad right so
please if you find him be gentle this is
his first week in Industry this is his
first job he's moved 500 miles from home
to come and work for fiser down in he
can he's also slightly bewildered
because he's started into this industry
where um people know how to do clever
things with SAS and he's never used SAS
before so he's going to have to learn
right now think back 30 years so if you
are less than oh I would say 40 the
thing on the far left is not just the
save icon but it's an actual data
storage device that holds a whopping 1.4
megabytes of information
megabytes but obviously over time things
have changed technology has moved on
we've gone through CD ROMs DVDs and
right now you can essentially download
almost an arbitrary amount of
information from the internet and from
the cloud so 30 years ago what's a cloud
well cloud computing isn't just
something that happens in the west of
Scotland where it rains a lot
right but 30 years ago the industry
really was predominantly SAS based right
SAS was the lingua franka for all the
work that was done for clinical trial
reporting and you know I would say 90%
95% of the work was done in SAS back in
1993 a full stack developer used one
tool this one but what they did was Data
manipulation analysis programming of
tables listings and figures right so
that was your full stack you did n to
end work but all of it
iness the other thing that happened in
'93 or or very shortly before 93 was
that R became a thing now back in 93 R
was more of a academic statistical
software for for statisticians to fit
models and do interesting things like
that it certainly wasn't the the
programming language uh that we we know
about
today let me talk also about regulatory
submissions so at the end of the
clinical trial development process we
have to gather together all of the
information that we have on our
therapeutic or or treatment bundle it
all together and back in 93 that
involved printing it out binding it
putting those binders together onto a
pallet shrink wrapping it and literally
Trucking it to the regulator agency this
is how we did so that's an example
regulatory submission and you can see
what kind of amount of volume of
information is in
there fast forward a little bit 30 years
on we are still producing largely the
same static information but it's now an
electronic format and there's an
electronic submission to the Regulatory
Agencies um but still you know we we've
come a long way but you know it's maybe
to someone 30 years ago what they would
see in this electronic submission would
be very
familiar so that says to me that you
know that there's a a well-founded
perception that Pharma is very slow to
change
right and I would also argue that
there's across all of the Pharma
companies there's a certain amount of
huus that says well if this isn't
developed my by me within my company I'm
not sure that the quality is really up
to fiser standards right and that I
think you know prevents us from engaging
with the open- source uh community and
bringing in in uh outside work to help
us with our
jobs but let me tell you right now
change is
happening pay attention to the the tense
there it is happening right it's h it's
not coming it's here now last week we
heard from Nova Nordisk that they had
completed and filed an NDA a new drug
application to the FDA predominantly
using R so using R and SAS but in the
tables listings and figures and data
manipulation used R this is the single
biggest question I get from anyone that
says yes M using R for for clinical
trial reporting is a nice idea but has
anyone actually done it you know in in
practice and the answer now is yes yes
they have if you haven't seen that video
I encourage you to go and have a look
it's really a great eye opener because
Nova are talking in very kind of CED
ways about what they've done and how
they've done it the other thing is that
the change is accelerating the pace of
change is accelerating and if you're
sitting at the sidelines looking in and
going Yep this looks interesting but
I'll I'll give it a little while and see
how other people get on with it you
might find yourself far further back in
the the change
curve so what does this change look like
well there's a collection of our
packages called the phae that helps the
industry with all aspects of preparing
for this regulatory submission so data
manipulation um tables listings and
figures and presentation of those those
tables listings and
figures as well as things like
infrastructure bits around environment
management also validating our packages
and testing our packages so there's a
huge amount of work done in here the
other great thing is this is work done
across a huge number of different
companies and as you can see here a
significant number of
people right so this is this is all
great information that you can tap into
and exploit and see how much of it is
useful to you for your process
today but it's not just our packages
that people are developing people are
developing training modules so this is a
great example where genetic have have
made their training course on open
source development and using GitHub to
develop new things and how to work in
that framework and then made it
available to any of us in this room to
go and evaluate this course and see how
it works and that's fantastic because it
brings all of our skill levels up so
when we ask how do we do this we can all
now work off that same Level Playing
Field of knowledge and that I think is
quite
extraordinary a lot of these initiatives
are powered by Consortium so there are
three listed here fuse our Consortium
and open source and Pharma and what
these consortia do is that they give a
plat platform for multiple different
companies to come together and discuss
freely but not just companies it's also
the regulatory
agencies in this our submissions working
group from our Consortium the FDA are
active members and engaged and they are
defining how they want things to be
because they want to shape what that
next Generation reporting looks like and
I think that's really powerful you know
rather than it being powered by Pharma
companies who want to do something fancy
the the The Regulators themselves are
sitting at the table and going well we
have a stake in this we want to tell you
we want to shape at what you're going to
do with this but these three
organizations are driving that change in
a way that you know I've never seen
anything like this in the last three
years last 30 years I would say that in
the last five years the pace has picked
up enormously even in the last two years
it's accelerated again so this these
consortia really are powering that
change you might say to yourself why
would companies share this knowledge
isn't that our intellectual property and
30 years ago yes if I wanted to talk to
someone in rash about how fiser do
things our internal legal people would
get rather Twitchy but if we do it
through consortia now in a working group
that gives us this Level Playing Field
that says anyone can come and talk at
this within this working group and it
frees us to be open and candid about how
we're doing things and try to find the
best way because it's not just fizer
want to find the best way we want to
find the best way and hear what rasher
are doing and Genentech are doing and
and all these other companies and then
help that inform how we move forward so
the IP now is people are saying well I
think the IP is in the treatments we
develop and in the data that we collect
not in how I C have visualization and I
think that's eminently
sensible so let's have a we bit of a
guess about what the future might bring
please believe me I am not you know
telling you that in 30 years we'll have
hoverboards because you know by now we
should have had them right so it's
always dangerous uh Neil Spar the
physicist says prediction is difficult
particularly where the future is
concerned so bear that in mind but what
I want to talk about now is some of the
things I see and the kind of directions
that I think are going to be important
so we all will if if you don't know
about quto you will by the end of this
this uh conference but the principle
behind quto is reproducible reporting
and I think that's going to be really
important to be able to demonstrate that
this table listing figure that I'm
producing can be done again and again
and again and if I feed that same data
through I'll predictably get the same
answer in the middle I'm talking about
web bar but really what I'm meaning here
is The Regulators want to have a little
bit more Dynamic review of what we're
presenting as opposed to those static
images and and listings and tables webar
is a good example because you can bake
that interactivity into a single HTML
document and that's easy to send to an
agency where sending a shiny app depends
on a server which depends on
infrastructure which depends on package
versions and a whole bundle of other
things that get a bit squirely and
difficult
lastly on the right hand side the theme
I'm talking about here is interactive
Graphics so the fact that it's echarts
you know pick your own it could be
observable it could be uh R D4 or
anything else but the point is we are
all looking for that little bit more
interactivity in our visualizations so
that we can drill down into something
and go what subjects are involved in
this data point or who is this person
here and can I see what other other end
points pertain to that
individual the other thing is that data
is all around us now 30 years ago if you
wanted to know how a patient felt about
a treatment and and their daily snapshot
of their endpoints you gave them a paper
diary which they filled in every day
they brought back and we digitized it or
you gave them a a meeting with their
clinician at the end of treatment and
they would ask questions but today with
wearables apps all of these things we
can get a much richer view a daily view
an hour byour view of the patients
experience so for example you could have
a wearable that measures Tremor and
Shake in a Parkinson's
patient
continuously which I think it you know
it makes the analysis a lot more
complicated but it gives a much richer
and more nuanced view of exactly what's
happening for that
patient another thing is that patients
are having a much greater say in what
the industry does with their
data so they may have may give consent
for their data to be used in its primary
use of clinical trial reporting and F
the submission to the Regulatory
Agencies they may opt out of secondary
use of that data for things like
building ml models or AI models and we
have to respect that patient advocacy
groups are now much more data literate
than they were 30 years ago they're used
to seeing data they have people in those
advocacy groups who can analyze that
data interpret it understand it and then
make a case for what they would like to
happen and lastly patients have the the
right for their data to be
forgotten so a patient could come back
and say I don't want my data in your
database anymore and we have to respect
that honor it and expunge it now again
30 years ago that would have been qu a
really big ask but um these these kinds
of things are are that we now need to
manage for those things so all of this
change means that we need to build trust
we need to build trust between the
developers of these packages who are
across all of these different
organizations we need to build trust
that if I pick up your package and use
it for my purposes I trust that you're
doing a good job that you've thought of
all the edge cases or you know you've
you've tested
adequately there's trust between um the
industry and the regular Regulatory
Agencies and that trust is built largely
through those consortia working groups
because we're talking about it monthly
when when we get together and obviously
it depends on trust between the patients
and the Pharma industry to make sure
that we are treating their data with
respect let me give you a little Caution
ril about predicting future
technology the the books that you see
here are what's called an encyclopedia
IA you used to find them in buildings
that were called libraries okay and it's
a printed volume and if you want they
had hundreds of articles about all kinds
of topics and if you wanted to know
about that specific topic you go to the
library you extract the volume you look
it up and you find out your information
those things went out of date really
quickly right but you know guaranteed
you'd find one a a set in in a library
and then Microsoft said well with the
Advent of the CD ROM and the DVD DVD we
can now go from hundreds of articles
about information to thousands tens of
thousands of Articles and we can have
embedded media Clips so that people can
see and get more information about this
and you know largely because information
goes out of date very quickly obviously
they could sell annual updates to this
product that's a great idea right that's
revolutionary until something like this
happens and now you've got an open
Community curated
encyclopedia with millions of Articles
tens of millions of Articles edited by
all of us if we have a a deep knowledge
of a certain sitcom we can go in and we
can contribute to an article on it and
that's amazing right it's revolutionary
and the other thing is it's available in
any browser on any device on your phone
on your tablet on your computer
everywhere you go if you're at a trivia
night and you have a debate with your
colleague about who was it in that film
that did that thing you can now look it
up 30 years ago this kind of
community-led thing would have been
astounding right still is quite
astounding but 30 years ago you would
have been laughed out of town so believe
me the change is here it's coming it's
accelerating and like the Wikipedia
don't let yourself be the Microsoft
incarta team sitting there trying to
sell a product that is just about to be
trumped by an open source thing that
will blow you out the water and change
your world
okay so with that I must say I'm out of
time um but like Nat tell you here's my
QR code for all kinds of links to the
things I've talked about and how to
connect to me so thanks very
[Music]
much thank you Mike um so we wait for
some questions here uh what is the thing
that exacts you the most right now that
you're looking forward to happening as
you seeing all the Sea of
changes I'm really excited about moving
away from static
outputs you know so the idea that you
can have nice
clear informative visuals which are also
Rich so you can delve into them you can
see different layers of information um I
think that is going to be just amazing
um but like I say it's dangerous to
predict where we're going to go
because absolutely anything can happen
and when you say you you mean like you
as in the analyst or you talking about
like your end users be able to do that
kind I think from the end user
perspective we can offer them a much
richer experience and a much more
insights into the the different layers
of data that we're we're
collecting well again thank you so much
Mike appreciate
[Applause]
it